Oh Mons new sultan Haytham Ventana
Kansai Eid was sworn-in a few hours
after the longest ruling monarch in the
region and the founding father of
modern-day Oman Sultan Hatem made it
clear in his first speech to the public
that he will follow in the footsteps of
the late Sultan we remain guided by the
late Sultan's wisdom going forward we
will preserve and embark on the
achievements he made this is what we are
adamant to do to follow in his footsteps
with respect to international relations
we will follow in the same course set
out by the late Sultan we will embrace
foreign policies based on peaceful
coexistence without any interference in
domestic affairs of other states the
succession ceremony was swift and smooth
dispelling any concerns about
uncertainty or instability in one of the
oldest dynasties in the Gulf region the
new Sultan will have several roles he is
the Prime Minister controls the
government the Armed Forces finance and
foreign affairs his biggest challenge is
balancing a budget that relies on
revenue from dwindling oil and gas
supplies the death of Sultan Qaboos
comes at a critical moment tension has
grown in the region after the u.s.
assassination of iranian military
commander Qasem Soleimani his killing
has shattered any hopes of a diplomatic
solution Oman has in the past played a
crucial role in narrowing differences
between the two rivals it has a
long-standing neutral approach to the
problems of the region in 2017 when
Saudi Arabia the UAE Egypt and Bahrain
imposed a blockade on Qatar Oman refused
to take sides calling instead for
dialogue it also plays a central role in
international efforts to end the war in
Yemen the new sultan has insisted he
will maintain his nations neutrality and
honor the legacy of sultan qaboos the
late ruler came to power in 1970 at a
time when Oman was underdeveloped
divided and facing a rebellion in the
South but haboos managed to overcome
those obstacles and turn it into a
modern state qaboos faced another
challenge in 2011 when thousands of
people protested demanding
her wages and more jobs as the Arab
Spring was spreading Sultan Qaboos fired
members of his government gave more
powers to the consultative council and
began reforming the public sector the
late monarch will be remembered by his
people as a unifying figure and by the
world as a shrewd politician who turned
what many considered a small country
into a major regional player Zane bus
Ravi al-jazeera Musto